[Applause]
classic movie there that is from the
movie whip it thousands of roller derby
players and fans are in town for
rollercon a celebration of roller derby
and roller skating jc fernandez is live
at the west gate with the over-the-top
details from the roller rink kjc
hey rocky it is intense over here at the
west gate i'm with wendy she's with
rollercon so what is happening here this
week oh well we have a lot of skating
going on here rollercon was started as a
roller derby convention and we've really
expanded to some over other social
skating as well so behind us is we're
gonna have a game that's gonna start in
just a couple minutes they're called
they're not matches they're games what
what's the object of roller derby what
are we looking at here once the game
starts when the game starts you're gonna
have four blockers from each team and a
jammer who is a scoring position for
roller derby
they will start to
start on the track with a whistle blow
fight their way through the other
blockers and then when they get around
to the back of the pack again every time
they pass an opposing player they get a
point what watching roller derby on tv
what is illegal what what you're a rap
she's a roller derby rap what can't they
do out there well there's a few
different roles on how you hit and
engage with people one is you can't like
elbow someone in the face okay so i'm
out there skating
we're out there skating what can't you
do i'm skating along you can't elbow
them okay all right you should not trip
them shipping is illegal all right or
push them or push okay those are things
you can't do don't do that now let's
talk safety bring she is our intern
she's also our official rollerblade
model step in here safety what are the
ladies wearing out there what are the
skaters wearing out there the skaters
are wearing a helmet to protect their
heads from concussion we have elbow pads
as well wristbands and i would send her
off the track because she does not have
her knee pads on
violation
off the track thank you thank you
okay how long does does a roller derby
game last we're talking 20 minutes 30
minutes how does the game last well
regulation play is two periods of 30
minutes each at rollercon we have a
little bit of a condensed version to get
everyone on the track that they that we
can so usually we run challenges about
their 20 minutes 30 minutes and where
are these two teams there's teams all
across the country we actually have
local teams do we know where these teams
are from i this is a mix of different
skaters from all over the world and you
have to also there's a professional
skate park track over there where people
are doing some stunts we're gonna go
check that out in a little bit and
actually coming up i'm gonna be joined
by one of our las vegas owned roller
derby skaters city roller derby sin city
roller derbies all right so no checking
is allowed you're right well you can
check i'll bring it all right bring it
okay
you want to get in a low position yeah
here comes the check get low and then
you hit someone with your hip
i love it wendy thank you so much
we're going to send it back to you guys
in the city oh my god every name jc oh
like jim and jc
let's head back to you guys jc my high
school basketball coach is watching
coach tony he would say i would likely
foul out
of the roller derby yeah
that was so much fun thank you jason
hopefully we can get you on the on the
rink
later on in the show maybe i'll get out
there
we'll see we'll see